une étoile jaune souvent symbole
toujours représentative de la seconde
guerre une étoile réel et inspirante
francine play a choisi de la décliner
des tas de gens pour protester contre
cette fameuse étoile qui estime à
stigmatiser toute une partie de la
population a trouvé le moyen d'en
fabriquer pas forcément avec les jaunes
mais des fois du blancs avec des
inscriptions fantaisiste de façon à dire
oh bah moi aussi j'arbore ça je ne suis
pas mais voilà donc il ya des prénoms il
ya des dates de naissance il ya un
certain nombre de données comme ça qui
sont réels comme francine 25 artistes
ont peint la guerre et ses résistances
acrylique collage impression le
collectif mémoire libre s'est bâtie au
sein de l'atelier d'arts plastiques de
maurepas et a créé une quarantaine de
toiles
c'est une aventure qui a commencé en
2004 ma fille faisait partie d'une
association qui travaillait pour la
mémoire et l'histoire de la résistance
et elle organisait des colloques des
conférences et c'est autour de ce thème
et elle nous a suggéré de travailler en
peinture sur la notion de résistance en
a travaillé pendant un an voire deux ans
pour certains et on a été nourrie par
des documents que qui était importée on
a eu messieurs stéphane hessel
ambassadeur qui est venu dans notre
atelier la résistance deuxième volet
d'une série d'expositions guyancourt a
choisi cette année de mettre en avant
les guerres ses impressions ses
conséquences c'est pour toujours dans
cet esprit du centenaire rappeler ce
devoir de mémoire c'est important pour
transmettre pour ce désir de transmettre
à toutes les nouvelles générations que
la guerre les douze les douleurs tout ça
existe et que ce n'est pas un acquis et
que tous ensemble nous devons résister
pour que ça continue
que la paix arrive un devoir de mémoire
qui se transmet jusqu'à la fin de
l'année
les actes de résistance exposé à
guyancourt jusqu'au 9 décembre